finally getting the official
confirmation yeah I remember there has
been a little bit of guidance on the
pricing initially people thought this
purchase would be valued at 3.2 billion
dollars for beets and then there was
reporting it might be three billion in
this news release from Apple they cite
the price at three billion dollars a
price that includes approximately 2.6
billion dollars and another 400 million
that will vest over time I think one of
the things that is everyone's been
curious about is the role of dr. Dre and
Jimmy Iovine the founders of this
company and and how they would play into
this and Apple is very clear in this
press release to highlight the fact that
they will be joining Apple which raises
a lot of questions about why this deal
was announced in the first place were
they buying it for the technology were
they buying it for the hardware were
they buying it were they buying it for
dr. Dre and for Jimmy and dr. Dre I mean
that that's that's been one of the the
questions that's been talked about was
this really a talent acquisition John
yes I think it is I mean I think we've
had a lot of time to digest this deal
because there's been a lot of reporting
on it and certainly for a company like
Apple which is looking to stay very
relevant in the minds of consumers
hiring basically bringing aboard some
very well-known players who in a lot of
ways read or transformed sort of this
whole electronics market listening to
music market over the last couple of
years that could breathe some new life
into Apple now I think there's still a
lot of things behind behind the stage
that we don't necessarily know about in
terms of what Beats has been working on
what Apple is working on long term which
could benefit the the company there's
also been a lot of discussion about you
know in a world where people are
listening subscription music services
maybe in a bigger way these days than
wanting to actually buy music like
through iTunes is there a benefit to
sort of making this bigger play into
streaming so certainly that's of one of
the factors behind doing a deal like
this having the talent like dr. Dre and
Jimmy Iovine another hates on stick with
us I get Julie here Alex here Eric Jimmy
here and you know we've all talked at
length about this one of the the issues
that has come up however is
whether or not this was the smartest
acquisition you could possibly make as
Apple if you wanted to get into the
streaming business because Spotify is
out there pandora is out there I don't
know how the valuations look but if
you're willing to pay three billion
dollars for something well your ground
ball had a great article that said dump
beats by Spotify for just a billion
dollars more you get what 10 million
pings per million versus one hundred and
eleven thousand ten million paying
subscribers 30 million free users
compared to one hundred and eleven
thousand so the average price like
twenty nine million dollars I mean may
that you wonder I mean because we don't
know the entire back story here who else
they may have approached in this
streaming business because to your point
I mean Spotify would theoretically make
sense you get a lot more for your money
beats themselves sources close to them
say that we know that our strength is
the marketing it's not really the users
it's not really the hardware or the
software it's all about the names right
it's like dr. Dre for example it's just
that brand name so they know that that's
their strengths so they can sell to the
highest bidder
they just need one company to buy it so
if it works for Apple and they've got
money to burn because they have a lot of
cash then it doesn't really matter if
it's three girls I'm John Ehrlichman
joining us with some additional news on
this story John well just to what you
were just saying culture and cultures
coming together is always an important
factor I think it's really interesting
as you look through this press release
Jimmy Iovine saying quote I've always
known in my heart that beats belongs
with Apple and then he goes on to say
when they started the company it was
inspired by Apple and so I think you
know when you talk about what Apple
could be doing having a partner who's
willing to come out and say that that
was always part of their inspiration for
the company to begin with would suggest
that bringing these two companies might
make more sense than something else that
Apple could do if the two businesses are
seeing eye-to-eye Cory Johnson I can see
why you know they would say that they
had been inspired by Apple Coria
of course joining us from San Francisco
just given the actual design of the
product what do you think it means for
the hardware side of the biz
so they gonna abandon that or do you
think they'll just rebrand it as Apple
Jimmy's being very clever with that
quote because when they when they launch
the business what they told us in bloom
of West is yes they were inspired by how
crappy the Apple iPhones were those were
the phrase that he would use and and the
sound quality and they really felt they
could bring something better to the
table now they've clearly by going to
Bluetooth by backing away from the hard
wire cabled headphones some of argue
that the quality has gotten worse than
those Beats headphones but fundamentally
Apple was going to be spending a lot of
money to develop better and better
headphones they've kind of acquired some
of that with his acquisition and this is
a well it's a ton of money the way that
Apple's generating cash has been unable
to put that cash to use this is
outsourced R&D in the most classic sense
of Silicon Valley acquisitions